hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one difficulty that many people
encounter in thinking through stoic
ethics has to do with the status of what
the Stoics called the indifference the
idea for a-- those things that are
neither bad nor good but somehow neutral
in between they lack the kind of value
that is genuine moral goodness or
badness doesn't mean that they lack
value altogether but they're they're not
the good or the bad and this is
something that gets brought up in on the
ends book three right at the very
beginning as a criticism of the stoic
system and the worry here is is framed
quite simply it's listen it you Stoics
are super hardliners you say that only
the virtues or only moral rightness is
good and only moral you know wrongness
or the vices are bad so you've got all
this other stuff in between you don't
really take a stand on that you throw
all of human life into some kind of
confusion or an inability to
discriminate and decide between the
things that we have to handle in our day
to day life because not everything is
about being virtuous all the time
there's all this other stuff that you
Stoics admit our indifference what are
those indifference things like health
and sickness or poverty and wealth or
good fame and honor or social disgrace
or whether you get the job or not or we
can go on and on and on and on with
examples of these and you can find
plenty of those discussed as examples
not only in on the ends book three but
in lots of other literature on or about
the Stoics so is this really the stoic
position it was the position of somebody
who is quite close to the stoic somebody
who actually studied with Zeno the found
of Stoicism and that is this guy r isto
of Chios who among other things he took
some of the stoic system and he said
this stuff over here the ethics this is
great physics and logic I'm getting rid
of that that that's worthless I don't
have to study any of that sort of stuff
in order to do epics right and it was a
very hard liner on ethics exactly the
sort of thing that Cato in in Cicero's
on the ends is having sort of thrown in
his face are if Stowe said you've got
the good you've got the bad and
everything else in between doesn't
matter at all it is strictly speaking
and different he'd like that part of the
stoic doctrine and everything that was
in different was totally indifferent he
said all you got to do is avoid being
bad avoid being vicious and be virtuous
and don't worry about anything else now
is that the stoic position that's that's
going to be a problem that the Cato has
to argue against what are the
implications of this well if only virtue
matters
there's no way or even any need to rank
or select or do anything with
indifference whether you're sick or
healthy doesn't matter whether you're
wealthy or poor doesn't matter none of
that makes a difference at all so what
is the stoic view the stoic view says
that indifference they are indifferent
in that that they don't make a
difference to whether you are virtuous
or vicious you can't pile up any amount
of wealth or bodily health or any other
advantage of that sort good-looks Fame
you can't put any of those things
together and get virtue or moral
goodness and thereby happiness out of
that if you're a vicious person doesn't
matter how much money you've got in the
bank doesn't matter how many you know
clones you've got lined up to harvest
organs from so you can live on forever
rejuvenate it doesn't matter how many
cars you've got in your your garage or
any any of those sorts of
how many people you've got you know that
say they're your friends that are going
to be there for you none of that matters
you're a vicious person you're gonna act
viciously you're gonna be miserable
likewise if you're a good person if you
have virtue you can take away all those
other things and you're still going to
be virtuous
so indifference don't make a difference
that way but they do make a difference
in all sorts of other things it's not as
if they lack value altogether
the Stoics say that some indifference
are preferred and some are rejected that
is they have a kind of secondary value
so health is something that is preferred
and it's preferred not only for its own
sake it's you know the Stokes would say
it's not good but it's preferred or it's
advantageous to be healthy and it's also
you know advantageous because it leads
to other things if you're healthy you'll
probably look better you'll probably be
able to make more money you'll probably
be able to discharge the duties that you
have to your friends and family or
country or whatever it's going to be
you'll have a longer life whereas if
you're if you're sick all the time
those things you know the opposites of
that will be the case all right so
indifference do make a difference they
just don't make a difference to virtue
they don't make virtue what it is they
don't make you a good person and the
virtues themselves do in fact bear upon
the indifference much of what count as
the virtues for the Stoics and let's you
know remember what those are the
cardinal virtues wisdom justice
temperance and courage much of that has
to do with all that realm of things that
in themselves don't really matter but
how we comport ourselves how we use them
what we do with those things does in
fact make a difference and so Cicero is
going to have Cato at several points
make some very interesting observations
the first of these is in Section 12
where he says that it is indeed prop
the word there is propria it's
translated here in this text as
essential it's on the essence of virtue
to exercise some sort of choice choice
where among the things that are in
accordance with nature
now virtue itself is in accordance with
nature right and virtuous actions are in
accordance with nature our human nature
fully developed but there's an entire
realm of indifference that are still in
accordance with nature they just don't
have a positive moral value they have a
value in other respects and virtue makes
choices among them it ranks them in
relation to each other it chooses them
and rejects the things that are not in
accordance with nature or if you have to
choose between multiple ones which ones
do you actually select if you have to
choose say between health and wealth or
choose between the job that you really
enjoy but doesn't make that much money
and the job that you don't really enjoy
that much but isn't honor us and you
might make more money in that these are
the sorts of things where virtue makes
selections and he goes on and he says
philosophers who make all things
absolutely equal rendering them
indistinguishable either as better or
worse leaving no room for selection and
the word there select selection is
select Sione right leaving no room for
that to be used to be employed have
abolished virtue itself there's
something that has to do with the nature
of virtue that it extends out into the
world of indifference and makes choices
about them this is even more the case if
we think about one virtue in particular
which has you could say a super status
among the Stoics and that is wisdom
because if you think about things that
are in accordance with nature and making
choices and and we might say prior
rising or rank ordering or however you
want to talk about your decision-making
process if it's virtuously oriented
justice courage and temperance will be
informing the way those choices work and
that's how justice courage and
temperance are going to to be enacted
are going to show themselves wisdom even
more requires that so in Section fifty
lead her on he's going to say and then
he says it's a little bit earlier on as
well a similar formulation if we
maintained that all things were
absolutely indifferent the whole of life
would be thrown into confusion
everything would be all mixed up
together he says as it is by Ari stone
so he's rejecting our stones point of
view and no function or task could be
found for wisdom for the virtue of
wisdom a little bit earlier he talks
about prudence not being able to be used
there and prudence and wisdom are really
in this respect synonyms for for the
same virtue the same disposition of the
human being and the Latin here is there
would be no munis or opus right opus is
actually doing something a deed right
there'd be no function there'd be no
point or task to having wisdom wisdom is
about actually making choices within the
world well informed choices she goes on
a little bit further and he says why is
this the case there would be no
distinction between things that pertain
to the conduct of life and no choice
would need to be exercised and this is
precisely where in the discussion he
brings up this notion of indifference
and he says here's how the Stoics
handled this idea so when it comes to
indifference we should in fact choose
the preferred indifference we should do
so in a way that's that's oriented by
and ordered by the virtues so we don't
just pursue wealth for its own sake to
the detriment of everything else we
pursue it within a free
work that makes sense that's organized
by wisdom that is enacted by justice
courage and temperance and so there's a
very important relationship in stoicism
that is lacking in some other doctrines
like that of ära Stowe and perhaps even
that of cynicism closely related to
stoicism that has to do with the the
role of the in difference in how virtue
works and expresses itself and Orient's
its own self and so this would have to
do with the nature of human happiness
because for the Stoics to be virtuous is
to be happy virtue is necessary and
sufficient for happiness but that means
that we have to not just withdraw from
everything else and say wow the world
doesn't matter anything other than hurt
you to really have virtue means to be
engaged with the things of the world and
making good choices among them
you